dr. bill warner holds a PhD in math and
physics he's been a professor of
businessman and an applied physicist he
now runs political Islam calm which
attempts to explain the unique political
aims of the doctrine of Islam dr. Warner
welcome to the Rubin report delighted to
be here well I'm excited to talk to you
because I saw you on a couple months
back with my good friend GAD sad and I
thought you laid out some extremely
complex and controversial issues in in
in a pleasant and understandable manner
and that's where a lot of this stuff
gets lost right we don't talk about
religion and particularly Islam and in a
real honest way that often doing well I
try to use what I call fact-based
reasoning which is a concept that used
to be quite common but is disappearing
from the universities now mm-hmm
as a matter of fact I was just down in
Florida and a president of a local
Community College said that I should be
censured and never allowed to speak of
course unstable because you were
unstable that's what they said I I wish
that I didn't believe you on that but I
know enough about what's going on in the
colleges to know that you're telling me
the truth so first off let's just start
a little bit with your history and what
led you here so for a man that has a PhD
in math and physics why in god's name
would you get involved in religion of
all things because i love history and
i'm also this might sound odd I've
always loved religion I've always seen
religion is one of the great
civilizational forces and so I've always
been interested in history is muted
through the lens of how religion affects
it so that's what started out of my
interest the I first interest however
was to actually study Sufism at age 30
which was 45 years ago so you go from
science and basically what you've done
is taken what you've learned in the
field of science and then you apply that
to studying religion is that fair to say
that's yes because one of the things
that's unusual about my study is is I do
a systemic study that is I study then
the whole thing not just bits and pieces
the other thing is I'm very fond of
measurement because once we have
measurement we have something we can
talk about between us that is objective
so I'm interested in bringing as much
objectivity to a study which is usually
considered to be well it's all about
feelings but I find this a lot to be
actually known about Islam right so you
go for the difference we talk about this
all the time the difference between fact
and feeling fact might make you
uncomfortable but it's it's a better
place to get true knowledge than going
for feelings all the time well that's
what I think now let me explain to you
this is sort of an odd idea more and
more today our civilization is based on
I believe two cornerstones an ethical
cornerstone of unitary ethics all people
will be treated the same and an
intellectual cornerstone of fact based
reasoning critical thought so that's
what I try to bring to the table is what
I think is the best of our excuse me is
the best of our civilization which is
critical thought yeah well we certainly
do need more of it so before we get
right into Islam which really is your
specialty you've studied a lot of the
big religions right can you tell me a
little bit about sort of who you studied
with how you studied why you studied
where you went to study the whole
shebang well I started out where like I
say studying Sufism because it was sold
to me as a Western mysticism and I was
raised in a very Christian home and so
it was pressed upon me the need for
religion to be integrated into life so I
thought well let me explore this because
remember I'm a scientist and applied
scientist and so I'm big on experiment
which way in my case mean actually not
just reading a book but going and trying
it so I tried Sufism studying with a
teacher for about a year then there's
some things about it that didn't line up
right to me and so I drifted away I fir
instance oddly enough I've studied Torah
the Orthodox synagogue here in Nashville
which is slightly unusual
I've studied Buddhism with Buddhist
teachers in yoga with yoga teachers so
I've both read and practiced yeah and so
that's what I bring to the table so is I
think some people watching this will say
that there's a inherent disconnect
between these two methodologies right
one we know is based on belief and one
is based on fact so how are you able to
combine those two schools of thought to
to even judge what is real about
religion well it to me there are three
great questions in life who are we why
are we here and where are we going now
you can be an atheist and have your own
answers as a matter of fact I perturb
atheists when I say include them in the
grant study religion because I say look
these are their answers to what I
consider three primary religious
questions so I don't if some would say
there's no reason at all in religion but
yet I say there is a reason and since of
we attempt to give the answers up why
are we here where are we going and who
are we so I try to bring rationality to
the study and also a calm tone of voice
I don't like people who interrupt and
only people who shout at me or anything
and become angry it's like chill out
let's just discuss this it may take a
long discussion but let's talk yeah well
I think you're on the right show if
that's if that's what you're going for
and that's actually why I really enjoyed
your conversation with God because these
conversations you know if you watch
cable news for the little bits they
spend on religion or belief or whatever
it is you know it's just these little
five-minute bites and they're yelling
over each other and it's like this is
this is what we need to unpack some
really important stuff so all right so
let's dive into Islam because your your
website and really your life's work now
is it's political Islam calm so when did
you really get interested in
understanding this sort of political
nature of Islam and can you explain how
that's different from the religious
nature ah you touched on what I think is
the most important subject here in
discussing Islam Islam is not a religion
Muslims will tell you it's not a
religion they will tell you there's a
complete way of life now I say that same
thing in another way which is it is a
complete civilizational viewpoint so
being a complete civilization it has
religion yes but when we read its quote
religious documents we discover
something very odd over half of them
are about me and probably you that is
the kaffir unbelievable well this is
very unusual because most religions
concern themselves on how to be a safety
study towards how to be a Jew so I was
really struck with this that how much of
the doctrine and by the way own doctrine
let's define this most people think the
doctrine of Islam is found in the Quran
but that's only a small portion of and
the Quran itself says in 91 verses see
my measurements I there 91 verses say
that every Muslim is to follow the way
of Mohammed called the Sunna and that's
found in two books hadith the traditions
in the Sarah his life his bark so we
read all of this it's overwhelmingly
concerned with as I say myself now then
I am NOT a member of the religion of
Islam so that involves me it is not a
religious involvement it is a political
involvement because the Shriya wants to
tell me what I can say and not say what
I can do and not do and so let me give
an example sure in you in Europe is
quite common other than in America we
find Muslims little on Friday commandeer
the street and pray you're less
religious ah is it the prayer is
religious but commandeering the street
is a political action and so that only
concern I don't care the prayer don't
pray that's not a concern about a
commandeering my street and not being
arrested I have a problem with that yeah
you know it's so interesting because
I've gone out of my way since we've been
talking about these topics since this
show started in September I always try
to separate the the average person of
any religion who believes anything they
want in the privacy of their own home
and doesn't as long as you don't chop
someone's head off as long as you don't
impose your belief I don't care what you
do it I don't think I'm not trying to
tell you how to live and as long as you
don't tell me how to live then I think
we're good to go but so there's where
you're making the interesting
distinction it's not about the prayer
itself it's about the other actions that
start sort of leaking into society yes
like on 9/11 it had a religious
motivation but I tell you when you take
a guided missile whether it started with
a computer chip or a human brain and
plowed into it economic targets that is
a
political action to me the auto
therefore judging on political basis
which by the way I don't like the
politics CS something else actions they
I have no opinion about the religion but
let me be very clear
I do not like political Islam why
because how it treats me and people like
me and then people say oh you're a bigot
you're a hater your race is yours
longeth oh wait a minute why is it when
I talk about how what I don't want done
to me I'm a racist Islamic own bigoted
hater I don't get this well also that
term Islamophobia a phobia is a fear is
an irrational fear of something but as
you just laid out quite cleanly it's not
irrational to fear something that would
subjugate you know I don't matter like
I'm real keen on the lack of subjugation
I'm notorious for my free speech and by
the way I'm a full-throated proponent of
free speech Dave because when we lose
free speech all those other nine Bill of
Rights things they're toast yeah freedom
of press what does that mean without
freedom of speech freedom of religion
what does that mean without freedom of
speech it is our most precious right and
it disturbs me enormous ly this is where
I grieve so much with sad is that the
political correctness is destroying our
ability to think what is only a nuke
lenola i think is a nation why do we
have left well it's a short step to
tyranny all right well let's let's make
this about ourselves then and talk a
little bit about the KO fears so
basically it according to Islam the
kaffir is it's basically any
non-believer correct yes now this has
some subtleties to it but what I'm for
instance when I was in a debate with the
Muslim Isis let me be very clear I do
not believe Muhammad was the prophet of
Allah and I don't believe and I believe
that the Quran is a derivative work I
said I claimed to be a kafir and and by
the way your pronunciation of the word
may be riot man may be wrong every Arab
speaker when they hear me mangle the
words always winces even if they agree
with me
Katherine is probably a kaffir I think
is like a probiotic drink mostly in
Turkey so let's make sure that I'm going
to go with your pronunciation okay so
good movie here I was talking about the
Capra it's so I'm very clearly a
non-believer
of Allah now there's some middle ground
here that both apologize for Islam and
Muslims try to strike which is to say oh
no wait a minute if you're a Christian
or a Jews and you're people of the book
and we're all members of the family of
Abraham see were one big nice cozy
family but as with so many things about
Islam read the fine print what the fine
print says is is that if you're a Jew
and you believe that Muhammad was the
final Jewish prophet then you're a real
person of the book well I doesn't remove
any to user with a qualify for that if
you're Christian and you believe that
Jesus was not part of the Trinity was
not divine did not die was not crucified
was not resurrected then you're a
Christian well I think we've just
removed all the Christianity out of
Christianity and all the Judaism out of
Judaism and so but if you meet those
criteria then you're a person of the
book
so basically Hindus Jews atheist
agnostics are all packers yes so that's
a problem because you see everything
that is said about the kafir is bad for
instance Allah hates cappers I don't
like that yeah that's not good we're
agreed in that that is that is not good
so as part of the issue here is just
that out of the big three religions that
you know out of the the three
monotheistic religions Judaism
Catholicism or Christianity and Islam
that Islam is just the newest so by
definition it was allowed to comment on
the others which gives it a certain a
certain more new world value or
something because it can say I look at
that old stuff and how we're going to
treat the people and those other ones
well it's true and basically this is the
claim of Islam is that Allah gave the
true revelation to the Jews and the
Torah and they changed it in order to
obscure the fact that Mohammed was
prophesied prophet and the original
gospel was actually for Jesus to say the
one who comes after me is Muhammad and
he is the one that is anointed well so
therefore they have perfect rear view
rearview mirror vision value well you
can look in the back and say see we were
that and we were the real one but you
changed it you Christians you Jews yeah
so one of the things I find when I
discuss religion and I
not a religious person but I find that
these ideas become political which is
why I end up discussing it a lot because
I do like talking about politics is that
a lot of my my friends who I would
consider more apologists for religion in
general but it's specifically for Islam
well they'll say you're just focusing on
Islam or they'll say but they're all
they're all nonsense or they're all
equally bad except that's not quite true
right because these these books are
derived from different things so can you
just sort of lay out some of the
differences in the book specifically
that that lead to actions well let me
explain something about the books now by
the way I'm going to stick with Islam
here the thing that is most puzzling
about Islam is is there is good stuff
and bad stuff and so this leads to the
question which is real for instance
there's the verse you have your religion
and I have mine let there be no
compulsion religion well that sounds
wonderful
that's right other unglue that if that's
all they were in the Quran I would be
like all right fine I you you have your
prayer day on Friday instead of Saturday
instead of Sunday but hey who cares
yeah but instead we find that that's not
quite it because the kafir is to be
actively resisted politically and it's
this active political resistance that
bothers me because this political
resistance includes violence a lot of
violence and so therefore yes we have to
answer this question which one is the
real Islam be good stuff or the bad
stuff the answer is yes right and
there's an actual word for that right
abrogation journalism well known is -
abrogation is in the Quran but I expand
that even bigger because you see not
only is the Quran conflicted so is the
hadith and so is the Sira so what I say
is Islam is dualistic it always has two
simultaneous views but on this discuss
abrogation yeah you have your religion I
have mine that's an early mekin verse
then the latter verse is left like
strike off their heads where you know
ambush them wherever you find them that
comes later
now the Arabs of Muhammad's day we're
not stupid they said Mohammed last year
you said this this
shir saying that what's up which one do
we believe right the Quran has three
verses which says the latter verse is
better than the earlier verse listen
carefully to what I've said it doesn't
say the earlier verse is wrong
so therefore when Muslims claim Islam as
the religion of peace they're right it's
just that they're half right the other
half is it is the politics of jihad
so therefore this dualistic thing which
is which is the real one and I like to
say the answer is yes it's both of them
but this gives the Islam an enormous
power because it can represent itself as
peace at the Interfaith gathering but
when it times turned when it comes time
to turn the political screws then
they've got the threatened violence of
the pollak political actions so this
gives Islamists enormous strength
because it always has whatever you need
to go to the back right and then on top
of that so you have this dualism and you
have this abrogation but then on top of
that aren't there verses in the Quran
that actually tell the believer that
they can lie to non-believers to to push
their ideology right not so much in the
Quran although Allah is the great
deceiver imagine that that's one of your
concepts of God is he's a great deceiver
but instead in the Hadi and the Sarah we
have deception let me give you one of
the most famous hadith Muhammad who will
kill ashram who has offended Allah and
His Prophet hot rod was a Jewish poet
who wrote a poem that ridiculed Muhammad
I will Muhammad but I will need to
deceive him do I have your permission
yes deceive him now this is just one
hadith about deception there's others so
this is one of the things that I find
makes me uncomfortable
not dealing with somebody who has a
license to lie it's so like James Bond
you know it's like double-o Muslim is
the hot it's like you know but then
there's another 12 verses let me bring
these up which have to do with deception
but of a very subtle sort there are 12
verses in the Quran which say that a
Muslim is not truly the is not the true
friend of a kafir now that's
harmful because for one thing our brains
are wired for sympathy but what these
twelve verses say is you're not to be
sympathetic with the kafir now listen
carefully you can be friendly a Dave I
just recently bought a car
I'm not going to upset you when I say I
walked onto the lot and suddenly I met a
lot of very friendly people how bizarre
they were not my friends not only never
mean to me anything but I mean look we
just met right
he's got my friend but you're very
friendly so Muslims can be friendly but
not truly a friend you see how I'm tying
this to deception yeah so that's that's
really good but anyway let me say this
most Muslims know very little about
Islam
so the professional engineer at work may
actually be your friend because he's not
truly Islamic and see you get it all
gifts it's hard to maneuver your way
through the social web here yeah so
that's exactly what I was going to ask
you so I know we see all these pupils on
what all people of different faiths
believe and there was the very famous
Pew poll about what the Islamic world
what Muslim people believe and it caused
a massive the infamous blow out on Real
Time with Bill Maher between Sam Harris
and Ben Affleck I'm sure you know all
about that
so how when you see those numbers those
basic numbers from the pupils how are
you able to negotiate sort of living in
the world you know it the the doctrine
says you know what the these numbers say
these numbers are pretty scary now it's
not necessarily scary it's not
necessarily scary with what there aren't
that many Muslims in the United States
there's no reason to believe that any
even remote percentage of them are
partaking in any of this but correct me
if I'm wrong but but it's a scary
proposition just to be in all that
here's the scariest proposition one of
the things I've done is to map out the
Islamic ation of a nation let's take
turkey for an example which used to be
Anatolia or Asia Minor it was Greek and
Christian today it's 99.7% Muslim and
only three 20.3% Christian now here's
the bad news this took
trees that is Islam uses a calendar
while we're using a watch now this is
very bad because the changes can happen
very very slowly and if you're not aware
of the doctrine you may not be even
aware of the slippery slope Iran here
with regards to the implementation of
Sharia and we're already implementing
Sharia here in Tennessee schools and our
textbooks so you can say well look it's
just one textbook in one class in one
grade wake up each other and you unpack
that a little bit what's going on in
this textbook sure well let me give you
some deep background over 25 years ago
in California there is a meeting of the
Muslim Brotherhood an agreed that one of
the best ways to bring Sharia to America
was to control the textbook process one
of the things I admire about the Muslim
Brotherhood is their soonest their
toughness and their ability to do
long-range thinking we've seen this
impact here in Tennessee because last
year we saw that first of the new
textbooks in what was called human
geography which purports English reports
that Islam is the religion of tolerance
that the Golden Age in Baghdad was the
high point of human history that Islam
was the first to give women their rights
and it goes on and on and on now some of
these things are half true but not fully
understood for instance let's take Islam
as the first to give women their rights
well it also gave the Muslims in Jihad
right to the right to rape kafir women
mm-hmm it also gives them to the right
to be take part in polygamy to have
wife-beating which is a right within
Islam so it's their right in the sense
of Islam gives women their rights but it
does not go ahead and tell you what all
those rights include yeah you know
interestingly I saw a video of 99% sure
it was an Al Jazeera video it was in
English and it was a young woman a young
Muslim woman describing how Islam really
led to modern-day feminism needless to
say the comments on the video were less
than enthused on her views on that but
it but it does go to what you're saying
and there's a connection to the Muslim
Brotherhood there and the way that
they're you they're sort of using our
system against us it sound it sounds
conspiratorial and that's why when I've
talked about it
people you know they they feel weird
about it like is there really was there
really a meeting 25 years ago to start
working on our textbooks and things like
that but you're you're laying out your
case
well anyway I've definitely laid out the
case I've read the textbooks and I can
tell you that it they tell it at most
half the truth so I say look let me get
this straight I wish that every school
would teach the Quran in its entirety
I wish that every school would teach
Muhammad in his entirety that's what I'm
for look I'm an educator and all I do
with my books and things is to bringing
the full complete story of Islam
Muhammad and Allah so I'm all for
education about Islam as a matter of
fact my whole life is devoted to it but
I want the whole truth right you know I
was in a court case one time and I was
an expert witness
I had to swear to tell the whole truth
and nothing but the truth because in the
law half a truth is a lie so all I want
is the whole truth and nothing but the
truth in our school system about Islam
yeah so let's back up a little bit just
to the life of Muhammad because when I
think when people when they say well
they're all equally bad or they're all
equally good or they're all equally
irrelevant or all of that stuff I think
what they're sort of missing is that the
the actual the sort of leaders of all of
these religions we're very different
people if you believe it right so just
real quick I mean let's just go through
the big three I mean if you were to look
at Moses Jesus and Mohammed they had
very different lives right
let me summarize Muhammad's life because
I think people are more familiar with
Moses and Jesus but let's let's let's
summarize Muhammad's life in about 60
seconds sure he preached the religion of
Islam for 13 years in Mecca he converted
a hundred and fifty Arabs I was driven
out of Mecca because the Meccan said
look you've brought us nothing but grief
argumentation conflict go get out of
here
salute to Medina which was about 150
miles north Groupon and by the way I'm
not making this up
he became a politician and a jihadist he
had 100 acts of jihad in the last nine
years his life not 101
99 precisely 100 that's one a month now
here's the drop bottom line when he died
every Arab in the Hejaz which was
central Arabia where he worked was a
Muslim that is review this the religion
of Islam was a failure
the politics of jihad was an
overwhelming success that is the summary
of Mohammed's life but do you see the
dualism here
the peaceful preacher and then the
violent jihadist which ones the filming
bill yes right so that that's really
fascinating and it actually goes to
something else that I've heard you talk
about which is that in a way that all
these religions they're not all designed
to spread equally that some religions
are very hard to get into and easy to
get out some are easy to get into and
hard to get out so can you lay out a
couple examples of that because I think
this is really fascinating and it's very
obvious and yet it's something that we
don't really think about well the
there's there's I've used some downsides
of Islam if you leave the synagogue
nothing happens other than what happens
in your personal relationships if you
leave the church nothing happens except
what is in your personal relationships
but if you leave Islam one of several
things can happen all bad I know one
apostate whose parents said we could
kill you but we will not never ever
contact us again you are dead to us that
is she became an apostate and it is also
the Sharia says there is no penalty for
killing an apostate
I noticed it doesn't say to kill them it
just says there's no penalty mm-hmm well
this goes against what I call freedom of
consciousness and freedom of religion
and I'm therefore maintained that Islam
does not qualify to be a corporate
member of our society if it so directly
rejects what I hope is one of our
central principles freedom of religion
make your choice I mean I just gave you
a brief summary of my own religious
progression
yeah I don't want to be gunned down or
bombed because at one step or another so
anyway I dislike the idea that someone
can be killed because of their religion
whatever it is yeah but it's not just
the getting out part it's also the
getting in part that's easy right so I
have heard you talk about this
get in right repeat in Arabic there is
no god but Allah Muhammad is His Prophet
and you say it in Arabic turns out I'll
only understands Arabic I guess it's
just kind of odd initially a Muslim I
won't ask you to do it in Arabic then
it's very easy to get in but it's
impossible to get out it's like those
when you're at the airport parking they
tow when you drive in do not back up
because those Tiger teeth come up so
Islam is kind of like those gates that
we see at the airport where you get the
rental car yeah it sounds like Hotel
California it's easy to get in yes you
can checkout any time you want but you
get everly exactly great lines in
rock-and-roll by the way there you go I
think we just got our promo for the
episode um so but okay so when you take
that concept other religions it's very
hard to get in right so I really well
I'm just really trying to lay out these
real distinctions other religions you
can't just say whatever it is in Arab
that language and get in right mm-hmm
that's just that's the Shahada yeah so
you know instead of doing comparative
religion although we can continue to do
this or compare it to our political
ideas okay yes you're quite right
imprison Judaism is notoriously hard to
get into I mean they really say you sure
you want to do this now right those are
much more big because they see
themselves as having a more universal
Charter but we need to understand that
Islam Chartres is I will wage war until
every kafir admits there is no god but
Allah and Muhammad is His Prophet
that's a forecast for the future I will
wage war until well when does that stop
well when we're all when there's no more
kafirs that's exactly what it says